[Musique]
en 1969 dans les profondeurs de l'espace
une mystérieuse valise était déposé
discrètement sur le sol lunaire par des
individus casqués que tel mais tel est
pourquoi l'avoir oublié sur place
cinquante ans plus tard une équipe
scientifique continue d'exploiter ce
dispositif pour mesurer la distance
entre la terre et la lune
leur arme secrète un télescope équipé
d'un laser ultra puissant
viser la lune ça me fait pas peur aux
physiciens
chaque jour ils orientent le rayon laser
en direction de notre satellite naturel
pour venir frapper les réflecteurs
installé par les missions apollo
à partir de ces mesures les chercheurs
vont pouvoir déduire la taille et la
composition du noyau de la lune est peut
être mieux comprendre comment elle s'est
formée il ya 4,5 milliards d'années
cette technologie de visée laser a
également permis de découvrir que la
lune s'éloigne de la terre de 3,8 cm
chaque année
quelques centimètres pour la science
mais un pas de géant pour la
connaissance
[Musique]